go you've got this video on YouTube a
Haven dance party in the car yeah and so
I wondered when did what your kind of
signature moves on the dance floor OB
yeah I want a demonstration exactly your
signature dance moves you can either
sitting or standing we're gonna do
sitting I guess
hey guys ready what are we doing here
our signature dance oh that's great
I've got a bogey in my back looking
looking really really good why I say we
good I really don't want to see that
later well don't sing we figuring in
season 3 and what direction are we going
with season 3 um we emotionally dance
the entire season but this season is is
darker it's scarier it's bigger than
both of the previous two seasons put
together I mean the the level of effects
and and stunts and everything just
everything got amped up this season it's
really exciting in terms of the troubles
what's the best trouble that you've had
so far and what want you most looking
forward to bringing into the new season
if you've been watching which I imagine
you have dear followers of Haven the TV
series episode 3 it is kind of like a
cult and yeah episode 3 the farmer that
that was a pretty wild one - bad teeth
making from the British
there's nothing about teeth what's wrong
with you this is like a what does that
mean that's not teeth I wasn't well oh
there's also the guy with the screwed up
teeth in episode 11 like it's actually
just Chiclets thrown randomly into his
face that's right they just put glue
there yeah and just threw Chiclets hmm
landed we couldn't afford we don't have
them but didn't have much in the effects
budget by then yeah Hank and yellow
why he was one that's right yeah I
wanted to ask you about how your
characters are developed in the show
since you joined um I mean all of our
characters have have evolved but I mean
certainly most drastically for me
Duke started out as very self-centered
and selfish and I think he's over the
course of the three seasons has learned
that he now has a sort of makeshift
family with these people here and and
and is genuinely invested in them and so
I think that's the biggest change for my
character I think the layers of Dwight
have started to have been peeled back
the more and more you start to see
subtly throughout throughout the the
time that you know I've been on the show
there's some history there dating back
to Lucas's Nathan's father and working
for chief Wuornos and now kind of
keeping that that lineage of the
relationship going but you start to see
that Dwight is he's a good guy who is
very invested in the town and his
friends even the people that aren't his
friends that he has a begrudging
alpha-male kind of vibe with there's
still that because I called sasquatch
that that's what did it that just set
set everything down the wrong path but
we still will get along and work
together when need be so I like that
aspect to the development of Nathan
Wuornos has been mostly physical through
the course of the season um the three
seasons like me remember when he first
met me mostly just one this side of me
and second season got a little bit of
left side and I'd say I'm like fully
Mobile in the third season and just
speaking muscularly just begun from
having an 8 pack when we started to a
four pack second season three pack
beginning of the third and 12 by the end
for a moment yes we're back Wow
no I started with at 8'o start with it
yeah so I'm up to 12 now I'm probably
going to drop it just go single pack for
season four okay
yeah yeah and I've been training my
veins and also um he has Nathan vascular
girth
very yes huge massive veins lots of
blood flowing through Nathan fixing yeah
we demonstrate our union position just
making your yeah I'm just making my
jacket little um yeah I'm busting out of
this uh my development
Nathan's developments was slow coming of
age story very introverted reserved man
and slowly through the help of his
friends letting it hang out a little bit
if you will just a little bit though
right yeah and he's sort of becoming
becoming a man before our very eyes
Nathan's gone from like not taking much
responsibility for stuff or initiative
to you know having to make decision
actually make decisions and then follow
through on things that I guess it watch
this chocolate or vanilla vanilla see
that's good right try me again
strawberry rocky road rocky road god
that was the wrong choice I got a stick
with it I'm gonna hate this ice cream
god I'm such an idiot yeah like now
Nathan finds themselves in situations in
season 3 where he's like it dude
wow I never were thought that I was the
guy that but you know what I'm gonna
take a cue from my my boy Duke Crocker
and be like all you know sexy is [ __ ]
can't see [ __ ] sorry or maybe in great
an acquisition shite sexy as shite and
continue and now I can't say certain you
can take lot oh yeah yep this sexy is
[ __ ] in this scene I don't think that's
how going to use it and now I did think
that was wrong
what Ireland you can say cut here - hmm
what about wanker
wanker you can it's all good good he's
saying then about you know developing in
different ways so I wanted to ask Adam
if you'd ever thought about using any of
your signature WWE moves on these guys
either in character or on set wait a
minute you have signature WWE moon I've
nothing like dance moves
sometimes I cut a mean rug the forbidden
dance was always my specialty yeah you
can't see it because it's forbidden of
course no I've never thought about it
never entered my mind well we had a wait
wait we had a fight scene we had a fight
scene which was a lot of fun but it was
great because it was close quarters and
it was you know it was in dukeship
so you're you're you have these
different elements of your fighting in a
hallway and you know not an arena where
it's wide open so it was nice to be able
to take you know what I used to do and
be able to translate it into something
but in a completely different
environment and I think that's that's
when I really started to kind of find my
comfort zone because doing something
physical helped me kind of get more at
ease with the the acting process how how
would you compare me to one of your
co-stars in wrestling you're very gentle
yeah yeah and but I mean skill wise how
would how would you compare me as far as
my fighting ability your your fighting
ability is actually very good yeah I it
was good good fighting ability and very
smooth skin very since yeah
thanks Jan yeah and I see you yeah
dangerous subjects you have very soft
lips not that I found that I've been in
the scene but when he sleeps sometimes I
do have somewhat full lips but they're
full of scar tissue were he's going soon
we were going we were going surfing one
morning and he overslept and we went to
his house in this little town where we
shoot Nova Scotia we went to his house
to wake him up and I was I was gonna
I think was gonna pour water on him oh
yeah he's gonna pour water on him we had
cameras but the room he was so pitch
black he had duct-taped the windows like
garbage bags stuffed things around the
cracks of the door it was actually quite
frightening like we all the sudden we
were like maybe he's a heroin addict
he's like he's literally like gone down
a really dark hole and like he like been
living in this dark room looks like I'm
dead yeah I know what they look like but
well you saw Trainspotting sure yeah
it's a bit dark although they were and
chains bottom the heroin den was very
colorful it was like red and green walls
um but yeah it was that was here yeah I
don't that's how I know about his lips
because I I was just feet I was that's
how I fish around for people I don't use
my hands I just circle it yeah I said I
mean as as like a gun most people do
it's one of your most powerful senses
yeah
well it's what you do right yeah so we
were in there we're like - I remember
like working again I'm working
oh well cuz we go up to his house first
of all more like oh then oh it's open
of course yeah so he opened the door and
then the cameras following balfour up
the stairs and then we open the bedroom
door and it's like let's get out of here
really we're just going on here and all
I heard was them whispering and I was
out you know out like light and I like
my room's very dark so if it's not like
at my home I have hurricane shutters on
my windows it it's a cave so I quickly
when I got there especially with the Sun
coming up at 4:00 in the morning and my
window is like now this is not going to
work there's garbage bags going on these
windows and it's going to look like a
crack den so that's what they walked
into I'm guessing that's just from
talking to you guys here now there's a
great atmosphere on set who is the
biggest practical joker and what is the
biggest prank or jakey played on one of
your other cast members so far
surprisingly it's none of us yeah our
crew are the biggest pranksters
it's our crew they and they usually that
their wrath is is pretty much always
delivered
and Lucas he started it's his own fault
but they torture him wave you started
some kind of game called [ __ ] you
Fridays and he started flipping them off
on Fridays right you'd write it on the
cement with like chalk maybe that was it
right so they torture him
what they didn't say fall they've filled
his trailer one day he couldn't get into
his trailer because they filled it with
balloons couldn't get in um there was a
giant [ __ ] sign that they made around
my couldn't get in
strange strange things left in my toilet
yeah that happened that's about it
you